more than a 100 police officers marching
towards the gymnasium where a bomb
exploded during a Christian religious
service on Sunday a show of force in the
southern Philippines to deter any
further attacks even though authorities
insist there is no imminent threat it
means that uh an additional policeman
will be uh seen on the streets uh doing
the police visibility it means an
intensified conduct of the checkpoint
operations and other anti-criminality
operations despite the assurances
however students of mindo State
University in marawi where the bombing
occurred are leaving by the thousands I
came here hopeful to change my future
through quality education with MSU but
right now I am leaving with fear in my
heart po knowing that something like
this happened inside the vicinity of our
University the predominantly Muslim
region in the southern Philippines is no
stranger to violence and armed conflict
separatist forces have made peace with
the government but small Breakaway
groups continue to operate they are
worrying enough because they actually
constitute a clear trend of continuous
Recruitment and squaring off between
forces of the Philippine government and
daa islamia in the past few months
nothing illustrates the situation better
than marawi the fighting between
government forces and the isol link
group here in marawi was the fiercest
war in recent Filipino memory that was 6
years ago but clearly with houses still
in ruins the city has yet to fully
recover the military says it has largely
driven out isol Affiliated groups but
admits they're still capable of carrying
out acts of violence bar below Al jazer
marawi City Southern
Philippines make sure to subscribe to
our channel to get the latest news from
Al
jazer